Rory written and the commercial world is
a world of material failures not
exclusively no no you'd be a very very
bad manager if you attempted to run
people entirely using numerical metrics
and incentives I mean the the more
astute business people actually not
quite as portrayed I think that's fair
because what I'm heading at is about
more what I wonder about is also related
to two to two remarks of over audio what
happened to our values you know why is
it that we started to believe that many
things commercial world wants us to
believe in are indeed you know the most
important things there are um you can
answer that in numerous different ways I
mean first of all what is innate in
human beings and to some degree like it
or not some degree of status seeking in
some form seems to be an 8 for the
simple reason that status is a scarce
good by definition in fact you can't
have a world in which everybody enjoys
high status across the board known as
you know not necessarily what do you
want to live in such place but what
you're suggesting here I suppose is that
you know people are being manipulated
and as a result feel their sense of
disquiet I think first of all we're
always looking at external agency is the
reason for people being unhappy first of
all people are innately a little bit
unhappy and or dissatisfied it might be
a better word and it's rather good that
they are to be frank that's the first
point you know the lot of man is not
actually one of unending bliss and the
eradication of all possible and I'm
Sorey rotation the second point is we
always blame things on external agency
but quite a lot of what is probably
causing disquiet in society is actually
the product of things people have freely
chosen to do themselves may see ISM
might actually be a very good
explanation for one of them by the way
urbanization you know patently you know
a society which was mostly rural and
lived in communities of 150 to 300 will
suffer a certain amount of distance
being rapidly exposed to huge numbers of
other people with no sense of identity
or indeed unit not even paternity and
there's actually a great correlation
tree that why did Neiman Marcus the
luxury goods store start in Dallas and
Houston not in Boston oil money people
arrive very rapidly unsure of their
status paranoid about their status
suddenly luxury goods sales go up
shortage of females incidentally also
leads to higher luxury goods purchases
on the part of men so um but putting
large numbers of people particularly
also the extent to which classes of
people now cluster together so closely
so you're in very very close competition
the banker who actually you know the
banking once would have thought himself
as immensely rich lives next door to
someone he envies so all those factors
like you know urbanization and and the
change in sort of demography and and
human migration which happens it's a
complex system it happens on the basis
of individual choice and some of the
consequences of those choices are going
to be slightly unfortunate well
modernity was not uttered is ver
modernity we live in a modern society
modern societies and modernity since it
came about first in Europe done by no
dude in the whole world has something
standing features but its characteristic
on maternity first and foremost it is
distribution through the market
redistribution if there is through the
state and that's a combination of
capitalism and socialism if I may say so
second is a dissatisfied society because
the first slogan of modernity was every
person every man woman are born free
never before have the utter descendants
it was an absolute sentence one was born
immersed and the other was born a slave
the moment we said all men are mostly we
created a dissatisfied societies because
we are not free enough because some are
more free than us we are not equally
free so everyone is this such as nothing
wrong with dissatisfaction
is what I want to say because this after
extraction keeps our society alive and
kicking in previous societies in
traditional societies if your
intelligence that they came the crisis
of course crisis I agree with you it's a
metaphor okay but according to this
metaphor the sick person either dies or
recovers normally traditional societies
die in crisis modern society for the
time being
recovers always from disguises crises
belong to the life of modern society
without crisis you cannot survive
without newspapers you cannot exist bit
of propaganda you can accept this
because we need to remain dissatisfied
you need to be able to say what exists
is wrong something else would good what
exists is ugly something else would be
dutiful what is exist at the most
important is unjust
something else would we just believe
from this sometimes we are right
something we are wrong than we give act
of propositions about this something
else when we have make the wrong
proposition disaster can follow as we
know in trouble 20th century but is our
responsibility not well Anna SH Heller
has just given a wonderful demonstration
what it is to be alive and kicking I
felt I felt the table vibrating under
the effect of it but I actually wanted
to say something else in response to
what Rory said which i think is very
important he referred to the transfer of
populations from small villages to great
megalopolis and how this causes enormous
disruption and producing itself at a
search for status of a new kind but I
think I would like to reflect on the
fact that the great cities that have
grown in the modern world have also
brought along with themselves an art and
a literature of loneliness you know a
loneliness of a new kind which you find
in already in Balzac but also in flow
Barre and of course paradigmatically in
people like Kafka and so on a central
european tradition
and it's as though our need for each
other Oh which is the thing that is most
beautiful in human beings it suddenly
cut off from its from its fulfillment at
the very moment when when it can be so
easily fulfilled based in so many ways
and I think this is a most interesting
thing to reflect upon you know that this
is the major translate transition that
we have that modernity has imposed upon
us this mass society whether we're
surrounded at every point by
opportunities by people by opportunities
with friendship and and also opposition
and so on and at the same time there has
grown within that this unassailable call
core of loneliness that very interesting
thing beautiful point when I moved to
London I grew up in the Welsh borders I
gained enormous ly in terms of financial
capital but in social capital I became
rapidly impoverished I have friends in
London who I've known since the age of
seven probably about ten of them there's
nobody I can really call on now to pick
me up from the airport
this evening with the possible exception
of my wife okay so in terms of the favor
economy all those economy is die out and
replaced by the commercialization of
everything another very interesting
correlation is if you look at American
voting patterns a far bigger than race
sexual orientation or anything else is
simply where you live if you live in a
in a town or city over 600,000 you're
overwhelmingly Democrat if you don't
you're overwhelmingly Republican now
what you derive from that you could say
that arguably rural communities actually
find that you know what you might call
free-market capitalism actually works
fairly well and is fairly amiable part
of their lives and their content with it
that everybody in larger cities feels
that something desperately needs to
change but to what they're attributing
their dissatisfaction may be entirely
the wrong thing for all of you but why
is it that we embraced in the 80s 90s
this model of neoliberalism why is it
that then that it could become such a
powerful ideology that for at least two
Paige we wanted to believe that the
financial world and everything related
to that you know would be our future and
why I guess it comes out of a sense of
collapse of a previous to see you know
seemingly viable models the sense of the
collapse of post-war social democracy or
least the crisis of post-war if we
aren't allowed to use the word crisis
social democracy there obviously the
Berlin Wall the collapse of the sort of
division of the world into two systems
and a kind of triumphant discourse of
neoliberalism that that you know was was
sold to us and that appealed to
something perhaps in many people linked
with this idea of endless progress and
growth linked in the way Rory was
describing with perhaps certain
illusions about infinite possibility of
course only for a minority of people in
the world but nonetheless a powerful had
a powerful kind of grip on us but I want
to come back I mean there of course
there was that feeling of a model
triumphant but if we're thinking about
modernity which Agnes is inviting us to
do I think one should hold on to another
side of modernity in this discussion
which is I'm thinking of zygmunt bauman
book modernity and the Holocaust that in
a way the question then of what it was
in modernity that doesn't produce this
kind of more creative flux and change
and emancipation but certain kinds of
risk and the pull towards the drive
towards the cattle world of camps and
extermination or the world of a police
state and so on which has to be also the
sort of other side of any conversation
about modernity presumably of the
emancipatory possibilities and that much
darker side and how one understands
those relationships because they're
clearly very modern forms of barbarism
they're not simply some archaic remnant
there's something that modernity
produced that that is extremely ominous
and that that's I historian I guess I'm
interested in the history of the
endeavor to understand those processes
and what they owe to social factors
politics but also to perhaps to certain
things about people to the nature of
mind the unconscious and so on that the
Frankfurt School thought about many
people thought about in the 20th century
I the book that came to my mind was
Erich Fromm's great book which I still
think people
you know it repays rereading fear of
freedom which was also translated as
escape from freedom in 1941 which was an
attempt to think about in a way you know
this could have put the the fear people
have of that freedom and in a way the
lure towards authoritarianism and that's
also part of the story of modernity I
think it's very important thing for to
cedron thought you said it's basically
impossible to compare gains and losses
that's our problem
you speck a spoke about about loneliness
that's very true
but loneliness is a loss but solitude is
again so you cannot this is what you
cannot compare basically I would not say
to look at this wonderful it's a
progressive epoch not at all I said it's
different from all the previous it was
different characteristics and the are
gains and there are losses I think
basically communities are lost in
modernity that's a loss but solitude is
one which is important for us single
individuals we can be alone